ostrich cheveux vets from Vienna is
reachable on her cell phone anytime
anywhere
she works for an Austrian company where
she is responsible for customer service
between phone conversations she answers
about 200 emails a day basically I sit
at my computer all day when I go home it
just continues I walk the dog then go on
to my laptop and check my private email
and that all the forums that might be of
interest
that's the forum of and Wilma had to
fill a specific out this hint in common
many of us are just like ah stupid the
International Telecommunication Union
estimates that about three billion
people have internet access and mobile
phone contracts are expected to reach
the seven billion mark by early 2014
growth has been so fast it's hard to
imagine that 60 years ago public phone
booths were the only option for people
without home phones now a counter
movement is taking off in Amsterdam for
instance a mobile phone free zone has
been established London also has places
where you can escape the sensory
overload of digital reception the
department store Selfridges has
introduced digital free silence rooms in
its flagship store stress researcher
Mazda oddly welcomes the offline trend
he recommends turning off your mobile
phone for several hours a day it's worth
it and it's also important that your
body and mind need a break to regenerate
and generally we can leave all these
things I've done without any disastrous
results another possibility is taking an
offline vacation in the countryside the
laws of our organic farm and riding
school in Austria offers just that here
the guest cell phones are collected at
the beginning of their holiday peers
that we see and our guests continue to
feel what it's like to get long offline
that they can occupy themselves with
their children partners in nature and be
independent of digital technology for a
few days at least
all napping is empathic assuming this
about Anna not a bomb on organized these
holidays all year long in their farm and
demand is
they built log cabins for their guests
of course without internet access or
televisions this is what TV looks like
here
ostrich sure events has booked a writing
tour at the farm yeah oh yeah - I don't
switch it off completely for getting
everything at home concentrating on the
horse nature and what the horse shows me
just enjoying it
a riding tour takes up to three hours
guaranteed cell phone free offline
vacationers can also go on hikes that
feature sensory perception and awareness
exercises training the senses of touch
hearing and taste flying on offline no
TV no cell phones fantastic a really
different experience free of electronic
media and free of stress histories it's
the hot models I'm taking this home with
me / - I plan to do without any media
for two hours a day I'll read a book on
my balcony without my laptop or cell
phone next to me and for some cool oh
yeah I don't have to be reachable all
the time it moves me emailed I should
listen you can tell the others about it
later when you're back in the rat race